Jennifer you've got a hairless one
mm-hmm
we've got a picture of you and that
there it is that's the cavity the
hairless went and then that's Grizabella
on the other side now very very cute
that's hard to love but he's so
affectionate and loving that's why he's
a big I think don't be aloof if you look
like that
he's cute
did you get them cuz of the movie well
yes I told Tom Hooper when I was on the
set I said I'm gonna get a cat named it
macavity and then I'm get another cat
and Mamie christabella and so that's the
cavity and Grizabella okay
I know Matthew Pagani I would say dog
person have both oh you both you've got
many dogs and cats okay yes like just
roaming around or kind of roaming around
that's good sometimes it's good with
that I like both sometimes it's nice cuz
cats are so independent right you don't
have to do the things with them and they
come up and they're affectionate and
they're just kind of easy they like
their own time I like my own to the dogs
you know need more affection any more
time
ya know you got you like cats up to a
point on the whole I adore them but I
don't like it when they suddenly jump on
you your cat Omi's in your face don't
turn around and show you that
I find that objectionable we did have a
cat going up it was a very strange
situation because it came to possess my
mother like evil spirit it started with
my mom used to do funny voices for all
animals if we passed a sheep she had a
funny voice with sheep and a pig etc and
then the cat arrived and she started
doing this cat voice but it really took
her over and it was a horrible horrible
person my mother was a lovely woman
church-going Christian philanthropist
rather proper and the cat would say
[__] feed me [__]
sometimes we'd say mom you said that
darling I promise you I have no control
over
[Applause]
[Music]
you